week ten is upon us in the National
Football League 2019 season we're
getting ready for the games the one
o'clock Eastern kickoffs and let's start
big cat with the Chiefs and the Titans
Patrick mahomes by all appearances will
be back three weeks and one day removed
from the dislocated kneecap the range
was always three to six weeks he's right
in the middle of that window full
practice on Wednesday full practice on
Thursday at some point on Friday I
assume he will be either given the
questionable label or no label at all
which will make it completely clear he
will be playing the Titans are a team
and and I think they've broken the
theory that that I came up with that you
claim you came up with that they win
when they're underdogs and lose when
their favorites they've been losing his
underdogs lately
and they're the underdogs on Sunday and
look anything can happen with the Titans
but I think with Patrick mahomes back
it's gonna be old-school mahomes magic
barring some sort of re-injury or
aggravation
I think the Titans should get rolled by
the Chiefs yeah I don't think they're
gonna get rolled I think it will be a
little bit closer than you're saying
right here but the Chiefs are gonna win
this game
I have no doubt in my mind on that and
that will be a bad quote when when they
don't win this game
the Titans offense continues to just be
so horrific and they had a little fool's
gold a couple weeks ago when they played
the Bucs
and Ryan Tannehill had touchdown drives
Mike of 10 yards and six yards because
that's where Jameis Winston did for him
he turned the ball over so so much so
often that the Ryan Tannehill did the
impossible I think he had 30 yards
passing in two touchdowns in the first
half which is pretty much impossible to
do so the Titans offense remains just
horrific the Chiefs defense is a lot
better I think everyone that's gone
under the radar it's starting to get a
little more note now Chris Sims has been
saying that for a while
the Chiefs defense is not what it was
last year it's better than that and
mahomes coming back I think the Chiefs
win a little bit close but the Chiefs
win bills at the Browns the Browns are
past the point of desperation mode they
essentially have no margin for error
they lose one game in the second half
their best case scenario is 9 & 7 and
that may No
get them in in the AFC I feel like that
they can muster away there oh and three
at home the bills I don't want to say
there are fraudulent six and two because
the last time that term fraudulent was
used on a Friday show it was used by you
in reference to the Ravens you said they
were a fraudulent four and two and they
beat the Hawks and Patriots since then
so the bills I'm not gonna say they were
fraudulent six and two I'm not gonna say
that I just think that the Browns at two
and six it's time for them to get a win
at home it's time for them to get locked
in and focused they have the Steelers
coming up twice at one point we were
saying all the schedule is really gonna
soften for the Browns it's not gonna
soften because the Steelers are not
gonna be soft opponents for the Browns
two out of the next three weeks after
this Bills game but I think the Browns
find a way some way somehow Freddie
kitchens and company find a way to win
this one I have no tremendous faith in
that it's a gut feeling it's time for
the Browns to get a win before they get
swept by the Steelers all right so one
correction I said the Ravens looked they
had a fraudulent schedule up to the
point and that if they beat the Seahawks
or the Patriots they just need to beat
one of those teams I would declare
myself wrong I have done so I've eaten
crow no pun intended with the Ravens I
am clear with Ravens fans they can stop
coming after me for this game Mike I
think the Browns as long as they stick
to running the football which we have
seen in back-to-back weeks the bills are
susceptible to that the Bay drian Peter
said had over a hundred yards of the
first half last week with the Redskins
they obviously had to go away from the
run because they were down in that game
Myles Sanders in the second half for the
Eagles two weeks ago was running wild on
that Bills defense I think the bills
defense is good not great and if the
Browns can stick to running the football
and helping Baker Mayfield here they
will win this game a last-gasp effort
this also falls into the category of a
team that just desperately needs a win
versus a team in the bills that maybe
doesn't need a win as badly so I'm
taking the Browns and yes I did the last
gasp effort last week as well against
the Broncos that loss this will probably
lose I will continually think the Browns
will keep gasping in and coming up for
air and they will continue to drown I'm
okay with
I like the idea of a possible Kareem
hunt Nick Chubb both guys in the
backfield at the same time I don't like
that it may add more stress and tension
to this whole Odell Beckham jr. not
getting the ball enough but it does
enhance the chances of a win if you can
compliment Nick Chubb with Kareem Hunt
who's back from suspension we mentioned
the ravers let's the Ravens let's move
to the Ravens now 6 and 2 at Cincinnati
the Bengals are Owen eight and when they
played in Baltimore the Ravens only won
that game by six points and when you
look at the Ravens upcoming schedule
they've got four difficult games this is
the ultimate trap this is the ultimate
pothole game that the Ravens can step
into and I think the fact that they only
beat them by six points back in week six
that's exactly the ammunition John
Harbaugh needs to get the attention of
the Ravens Ryan Finley is getting the
start at quarterback for the Bengals all
indications here are the Ravens should
blow them out and I think they will but
they need to be focused or they could
find themselves with one of those
outcomes and they've been three or four
of them this year where we look at them
in hindsight how the hell that happen
how they help the Jets beat the Cowboys
how the help that Browns beat the Ravens
how the hell'd the Bengals beat the
Ravens I don't think we're gonna be
saying that on Monday if the Ravens
properly focus on this opponent yeah the
Ravens are gonna win this game I have no
doubt in my mind but to steal a phrase
from you I'm gonna thread the needle
even though it's a ten and a half point
spread so it's not really threading the
needle it's a huge margin there I think
the Bengals will be competitive coming
off of I new quarterback there's always
that new quarterback bump that you can
see is unless unless Ryan Finley is just
a horrific horrific quarterback you can
usually get a nice little bump guys
block a little bit harder the team has a
little more pep in their step when they
have a quarterback come in and give them
a different look the Ravens coming off a
fantastic win on Sunday Night Football
against the Patriots it is very hard to
get up week a week after that when
you're going to sleepy Cincinnati and
playing a 1 o'clock game so I'm gonna
take the Bengals plus 10 the Ravens are
gonna win and that's my Mike Florio
thread the huge needle lock of the week
I thank you for that lions and the bear
Seifer giving me a hard time about
threading
you know now you have to talk about your
Chicago Bears three four and one Lions
who should be much better than that
Bears are three and five and it feels
like they're worse than that they get a
home game they have a dome team coming
into town I believe in the Bears this
week I just feel like they're not gonna
lose every remaining game on their
schedule they were capable of winning
three in a row I just feel like it's
time doesn't it feel like it's time for
you you're not capable of being
objective you just think they're gonna
lose every game from now till they
disband the franchise I don't win on
Sunday Mike listen when when things
start going south I want them to go all
the way south you know what are the
Bears I know they don't have their
first-round draft pick do you want the
Raiders to have a higher promise Hank
for the Raiders listen Mike all I'm
saying is there's clearly there needs to
be changes in House Hall and this season
has been an absolute disaster and I this
is one of those games I'm not expecting
the Bears to to play very well because
they have not shown what are they shown
in the last few weeks like okay an
Eagles second half yeah they played well
against the Eagles in the second half
but how can they they haven't put
together for good quarters since the
Redskins Monday night game and actually
that wasn't even for good quarters
because if you remember that game it was
the Vikings actually let me say that
against your Vikings which is pathetic
to think about how bet how badly the
Bears beat their faces in I think when
this game starts if we get a three and
out from this offense if we get double
three announce from this offense like it
happened last week in Philadelphia where
they had a single yard passing yard in
the first half this defense will quit
and I think the defense is phenomenal
the defense has won games statistically
for this offense and they haven't been
able to the office hasn't been able to
even muster up an effort that would win
any other team a game in the NFL but I
think this defense is teetering as well
Hakeem Hicks being out since his injury
it has been a different looking defense
he was always a crucial anchor in that
defense I just don't have any trust in
mr. risky I have no trust in Matt naggy
I don't Mike what am I gonna do what am
I gonna do right now I'm pleading with
you what am I going to do what am I
gonna do telling you right now that the
Bears are gonna show up and somehow
be a different team than I've watched
for the entire season
are you a bench true Biscay input chase
Daniel back in the game guy sure I don't
know I'm a I'm a why not run the
two-minute offense with mr. risky all
game long I'm a why not install the
Lamar Jackson offense with mr. risky all
game on
I am a if you are still saying to
yourself mr. Biskit we got another year
of him controlled why not try everything
with him instead of coming out and
saying Mitch we're now throwing
downfield you're gonna throw it
underneath
you're gonna look confused it's gonna be
a disaster week in and week out try
something different
run tempo run lamar jackson off and let
let mr. whiskey use his feet let him go
you know RPO i don't know do something
different because what you're doing week
in and week out does not work one more
quick question on this and then we got
to get in a quick preview of the Giants
Jets game are you of the mindset that
they should get rid of true Biscay after
this season or bring in someone to
compete with him supplant him or compete
with him in 2020 what's your preference
well what is it what's the cap situation
I think we the money's already kind of
paid right so why not just have him
compete against someone I think that's
probably the answer you just bring
someone into competing the Bears are not
gonna go get another quarterback until
they start getting back in the first
round
so I don't know the whole thing is the
whole thing is a big problem Mike and
it's clearly making me angry and I'm
very upset that you're wearing a bear
shirt to mock me today that's exactly
why I did it hey last I know United's
way there's no reason to watch the
Giants and the Jets except for this the
black cat big cat is still loose it is
still loose I that he's still loose or
she the black cat may make an appearance
during the game on Sunday Mike I
actually am excited to watch this game
because I think the loser of this game
that coach is fired Adam GaSe obviously
one year in so it's gonna be you know
it's you don't see teams do it off and
he did see the Cardinals do it last year
he's not Joe Douglass's guy so he is
always on the hot seat because the Jets
hired their coach before they hired
their GM which never works out but Joe
but Joe Douglas is gay
guy that's the problem right but it's a
Douglas was handpicked by gays right but
that's that's not how though I mean the
hierarchies flipped upside down so as
soon as I mean Joe Douglas is gonna get
to fire him if he wants to fire him
wouldn't you say yeah well here's are
you saying whoever loses the coach gets
fired now are you saying that at the end
of the season because the other thing I
wanted to bring up to your attention Pat
Shermer when he was asked this week how
losing wears on him he said I'm built
for this that's not a quote you want out
there Mike he's built for losing yeah
Lamar Jackson is unaffected by
circumstance stakes day night opponent
he just goes out in place Kirk Cousins
is hyper aware of how big of a game it
is how many people are watching is it a
night game is it a big game are there
playoff implications and he holds the
ball too tight he sails the ball over
the heads of open receivers he did that
multiple times on Sunday against the
Chiefs cuz it was a big game he's gonna
do it again on Sunday night cuz it's a
big game against the Cowboys at some
point it's gonna manifest itself because
he is incapable of just forgetting about
the situation and just playing football
he can do it when it's not a big game
when it is a big game that's when he
freaks out that's my take Cowboys win
okay well how about Jason Garrett in a
big game cuz he it's not so great as
well I mean he's had some struggles in
big games in prime time games Mike I
want I want to figure out this stat it
dawned on me the other day we talked
about Kirk Cousins stats all the time
against winning teams and primetime
games
give me the reverse it must be
incredible seeing Kirk Cousins against a
losing team at one o'clock like those
those must be the most insane stats of
all time so I want to see that I want to
rebrand Kirk Cousins I want to throw
those stats out there because all we
talk about is how he stinks in the big
game he stinks against winning teams
well guess what Mike I'm gonna flip it
and reverse it on you I'm gonna say Kirk
Cousins gonna win this game and maybe
get it you like that on Sunday night he
says so Kirk Cousins is the best
quarterback in NFL history when the game
doesn't matter correct that's one
o'clock one o'clock a noon kickoff in
Minnesota against a team that is under
500 by the
the year what is Kirk Cousins record
all-time it's probably incredible and
the key is gonna be Dalvin cook yet
again if he can run the ball and they
can move the chains that way it's gonna
make it four easier for Kirk Cousins I
still don't have faith when the game is
on the line and at some point it will be
Panthers Packers Lambeau Field the worst
thing that could happen in the Panthers
last week was the the Packers getting
the crap beat out of them by the
Chargers I think the Packers gonna be
locked in they're gonna be ready for
this one Kyle Allen's gonna get a rude
awakening this is very simple Kyle Allen
Aaron Rodgers give me Aaron Rodgers yeah
I don't disagree with you on who's gonna
win the game straight up but five and a
half for the Panthers and guess what the
Panther can be able to run the ball Mike
because the Packers defense has not been
able to stop the run and they've been
you know member week week one two three
when we were talking about how great the
Packers defense was well turns out
everyone has looked great against Matt
Nagy and mr. Biscay this year so we got
a little over our skis on that one I
think the Panthers will hang tough in
this game Packers will win but the
Panthers are gonna be able to move the
ball with Christian McCaffrey and and if
they can kind of shorten the game by
running it and running it and running it
some more it will be a fourth quarter
game where where Aaron Rodgers will have
to make plays he will but it will be
close
I like the Packers to cover the Rams
Steelers sneaky great game Rams lose
that's gonna make it very difficult for
them to get to the post season the
Steelers have dug out of the September
stench as Mike Tomlin called it they've
gone four and one over the last five
games you know I felt this way last week
there's something about Heinz Field
there's something about this this zone
that the Steelers have slid into it
doesn't matter who the opponent is it
doesn't matter what it looks like on
paper they're gonna find a way to win
this it's not gonna look pretty it may
take another field goal that is 50 feet
wide left at the end like it took last
week to beat the Colts bounce of the
ball bad call bad karma something I feel
like the still this is just pure
visceral being around Pittsburgh most of
my life this just feels like a game that
it lines up for the Steelers to end up
with more points in the Rams no matter
how they do it I feel like they're gonna
do it I agree I agree I've been high on
the Steelers for a few weeks now I think
their defense is days kind of picked it
up here they're finding ways to
games they're doing it in an ugly
fashion like you said but the Steelers I
think will get into the playoffs I bet
on them in the future to get into the
playoffs two or three weeks ago when
they were under 500 so I am all in on
the Steelers getting back into this
playoff picture and it starts on Sunday
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports